all right welcome to a new video this
will be one of those pure entertainment
stuff one minute bullet tournament in
your chest cube I posted one of those
couple of days ago and yeah most guys
liked it so are we doing it again just a
30-minute tournament I didn't do any
warm-up games again so I hope that the
first couple of games won't be too hard
because I really need to get into those
kind of quick play mode oops yeah don't
want to lose the bishop with a five
okay so let's play some crude threads
here and it paid off cannot recapture
yeah this is checkmate very nice okay so
quick win always helpful now some pretty
high rated guys IAM because i dunno if I
just master always very quick ok so oops
I could have taken your phone let's take
the chance to maybe get some something
quick going e on the H file and camp
okay let's grab the exchange shouldn't
be too bad and the h6 also hanging
what you go to h5 of the Queen some try
to dislodge this night here
camera exchange up here but still
slightly tricky oh no it's not tricky
anymore just winning the Queen here okay
so two rather quick wins you 4g phone
okay
try to play sort of reverse chrome
pre-attack here that's are often very
very rewarding in bullitt it costs you
have cut sound so straight taking plans
for Bishop age 394 and stuff and white
needs to defend accurately I mean you
can it's not winning or something but so
I'm always tricky so come on let's use
all the PCM g-form coming up okay I'll
take it but at least this way e block
the diagonal here
and I want to play a form open up the
position even further there's a4 move of
course very young very strange just down
just weakens White's position for no
good reason ok I can actually take here
let's check out now recapture quite a
big fork here Bishop f5 winning another
temple or the Queen also look bad ok
well some guy actually 14 games I've
didn't feel to me like I was so so slow
but oops
okay try to overrun black here some
quick taking moves I'll be tuned should
have paid more attention okay I can also
go to a four hours a night if you place
before then be success a weakness wow
this looks very dangerous if you ask me
for black okay
all right so is there checkmate maybe
not but it's looking terrible yeah if he
blocks this now i have a problem with
taking because h6 is also hanging so i
cannot really take with the corn what
this looks nice now King g6 Bishop g4
check made or King GA to Queen HH Ahmed
yep I'm a gender couple of moves all
right what's this I didn't get any
points for this hey this was fourth win
and now I got got the points took took a
while
right some we had scotch tab of opening
okay I'll take it and this one also hmm
ok take the assembled I've queen edge
for coming up for me okay let's play
this one protect f7 this is the easiest
spend some time down and this wasn't
really necessary the position is very
nice but the time yeah grabbing the rock
man this is made alright so I'm in the
cold etm to other guys also i have five
out of five all right quick resign yep
quite similar set up two to one of those
earlier games now he goes f4 okay
interesting okay I like to get rid of
Bishop here okay cannot take I actually
can write yeah I can I have this move
here protecting the night okay so Knight
f6 he might just see much might
sacrifice here I was hard to slow I mean
what is playing is not working at all
but I was by far too slow
and what most it has spent all this time
are now blundering inform very stupid
game I should resign really okay where's
this bloody button ok I have what was i
doing down spending far too much time ok
this is not the most correct opening
ever but I think I've got quite some
pressure here the special p.m. does have
ok this one's a queen have for all right
so this silly lost didn't hurt so much
still on in the lead ok let's try for
some quick aggressive play here
so I'm got the bishop pair always nice
they're all so much better open
development here okay now 93 is a
problem frame and now d-3 and the rook
was hanging so it's about to loose
material that now this night also is
gone
yeah doesn't have so many moves here no
made the certainly was some quicker way
to do this but okay it looks like looks
like enough yeah yeah okay name is a win
but lost quite some time down our
custody know yeah I have a ridiculously
high scores this opening no no idea why
really
yeah black black and trouble here I've
got the a poem for nothing now it just
gave me the sir this right here okay
let's exchange Queens oops come on so
right here
all right I didn't have any time to do 2
comments on this it was just 23 over
time okay so um oops yeah I would have
been heartbreaking to lose this on time
after this pretty clear um game okay
couple of what peace and peace up yeah
alright so the sriman struck again
people simply don't don't know how to
play this yeah mmm well the bishop is
also hanging pretty quick quick one here
some yeah it looks quite quite promising
so I got the H file open as always
potentially very dangerous oh no this is
more than dangerous know what is he
doing against Bishop g7 yeah I think he
needs to play a move like this here ok I
want to want to attack here attack
further yeah this is made now Queen h7
made on Queen h8 mate what the ISIS we
can only prevent one oops alright so
close to 30 points ahead here it's not
so much sounds like a lot but this is 11
and a half game so to say so if I can
lose one and the other guy is winning
one and we easily swap places this is
very readable but you played this super
quickly
I'm just material up but
maybe here threatening this discovery
and still it's nice hanging so I'm going
to take care I think so so here here
you know position is very nice and oily
spanked the too much of time you yeah if
it was very slow at the end thankfully
okay so still 30 points i had 10 minutes
to go quite where the opening here but
it looks nice open position and two
bishops and can't ask from for much more
besides being a lots of who tol up to
bishops and an open position is nice Oh
ship to have six now this looks a very
dangerous for black 96cm it needs to
play now oops right and I true computer
star prolonging the end right
quite nice but those this guy here is
still closed that can I can change very
quickly in those bullet tournaments
especially if I don't get games need a
game here come on okay
yeah just post to our french exchange
yeah I've got c6 covered so this night
move doesn't do much I cannot look not a
problem oh I take on a three now of us
looks nice clean edge three go into h3
it's a huge threat which she didn't
attend to yeah I cannot coverage to rad
yeah yeah this was so nice one quick
quick quick made coming cool let this
guy is also winning are this another guy
he's winning all these games just a bit
slower ok let's trying to play in the
center here if so I want to really want
honor to sacrifice on f7 ok so maybe I
can can open the position here I was
going to h1 to prevent maybe I take
leadership yeah this is better King text
we should be five as a check I went to
edge h1 to get out of the checks here on
this diagonal be 62 g 1 and 93 check and
stuff like this yeah right so what's
really lost ok six minutes to go
yeah let's go for this Schliemann again
people are often completely irritated
they like here funny just one the night
okay every piece of and I should try to
to make quickly if possible I go from
for long castle here and yeah grab here
94 okay with this also good
strengthening move okay oh ok helpful so
50 points ahead but it's not over oops
to h3 this is weird okay
so what what yeah with a ginger swing
material that didn't have any square
funny came here okay I'm but she was
quite quite quick and playing all these
moves yeah can use opinion so we at game
okay now i'm getting really optimistic
here that are actually can win this I've
been overtaken so often close to the end
of those tourney sound really really
cautious with any predictions okay oops
hmm
and irritating this position somehow the
gphone that's a bit in between
convenient here no structural point of
view am great but ok this is a bullet
not so much about structures
yeah in a normal game what is just
winning but still has some chances here
to to maybe a drum up some attack oops
come on yeah but now with the Queen up
this should really be enough just push
the Jeep porn oops okay alright so now
still 70 points ahead and two minutes
ago this would be the mother of all
caches if he still had just to overtake
me like win five games with instant
resigns but this is impossible of course
this the same weird play as before let's
prevent 95 this irritated me
okay it looks like pretty normal
position now I'm going to play out a
form of for Bishop age three
yeah f3 is a nice point of a tech here
you just gave me a piece I mean it was
dangerous but not not necessary to to
second piece yet can always take root
III and I could have taken with the
Queen all cells be much simpler ok
quindi to mate right cool so 70 points
pretty pretty clear with Korea ok just
six seconds to go so we won't finish
this game how quick was this guy 107 now
I mean ok they get the bonus because of
the rating difference but still ok yeah
thanks for watching pretty entertaining
a tournament i think all wins besides
the one we're sort of forget to move
alright thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it and i'll be back soon with
some more serious serious chest stuff